Salut les curieux de nature ! J'imagine que
beaucoup d'entre vous ont reconnu dans cette
petite introduction, la Mésange bleue : ce petit
passereau est l'un des plus communs dans nosjardins.
Mais il est loin d'être le seul ! Alors
vous l'aurez compris, pour ce nouvel épisode de
notre série "La Vie Secrète du Jardin", je vous
propose un focus sur les oiseaux. Générique !
Dans un jardin qui laisse de la place
à la nature, il ne sera pas difficile des'initier à l'ornithologie :
cettescience, dédiée à la connaissancedes oiseaux est souvent
pratiquée par des amateurs.
Pour se lancer, rien demieux que d'apprendre à différencier les
différents oiseaux de notre quotidien.
Il existe une multitude de livres
et de sites internet pour cela.
Pour attirer des oiseaux chez soi, on pense souventà
installer une mangeoire : c'est-à-dire un point de
nourrissage, où l'on va déposer des graines
ou des boules de graisse végétale.
Toutefois, cette pratique doit rester très ponctuelle
et n'est à garder que pour les gelées de l'hiver.
Le reste de l'année, rien ne remplaceraune haie qui mixe
des arbres, des arbustes et des plantes judicieusement choisis.
On peut aussi y intégrer des tas de branches, qui attireront des oiseaux
qui aiment évoluer plus près du sol.
Tout cela engendrera une grande diversité
de fruits, de graines et d'insectes.
Il ne sera donc plus nécessaire de nourrir
qui que ce soit, les oiseaux le feront tout seul :
chaque espèce avec ses habitudes
et son propre régime alimentaire.
Mésange charbonnière, Rouge-gorge familier,
Moineau domestique, Grive musicienne,
Étourneau sansonnet, Merle noir,
Pigeon ramier, Pinson des arbres, Troglodyte mignon,
Verdier d'Europe, Chardonneret élégant, Sittelle torchepot,
Pivert, Pic épeiche et j'en passe...
L'oiseau qui partage ici si son quotidien avec
nos poules, c'est l'Accenteur mouchet.
Si son nom n'est pas connu de grand monde, il fait
pourtant partie des oiseaux les plus communsdans un jardin.
Malheureusement, beaucoup le confondent
avec le Moineau domestique.
Bah oui hein, c'est bien connu : un petit oiseau gris et marron
c'estforcément un moineau.
L'Accenteur mouchet évolue souvent au sol, où il va trouver
l'essentiel des insectes qui constituent sonrégime alimentaire.
Son plumage terne est idéalpour se camoufler.
On dit qu'il est cryptique.
Cet oiseau mène une vie assez discrète, souvent
dissimulé à l'ombre dans les fourrés.
Un habitat qu'il partage d'ailleurs avec le plus petit
des oiseaux du jardin : le Troglodyte mignon.
Au même titre que l'installation d'une
mangeoire, la pose de nichoirs est une
action assez simple à mettre en place dans
un jardin pour protéger les oiseaux.
Elle permet d'offrir un lieu de ponte aux
espèces dites cavernicoles : c'est-à-dire
qui élèvent leurs petits dans des
cavités ou des trous.
Un simple pot en terre peut suffire au Rouge-gorge.
Il suffitsimplement d'ouvrir un petit peu le trou.
Mais l'un des nichoirs qui rencontre le plus desuccès
est sans aucun doute celui dit "boîte aux lettres".
Il fait la joie d'unautre passereau, très commun dans
nos jardins : la Mésange charbonnière.
Fait principalement de mousse,
de poils et d'herbes : le nid de
la mésange est construit par la femelle.
Elle peut être ravitaillée par le mâle
qui s'investit surtout dans la défense duterritoire.
Durant cette période les intrussont
immédiatement chassés, entraînant même
parfois des rixes contre leur propre reflet.
Si la période des nourrissages
permet d'observer plus facilementles mésanges,
il ne faut pas oublier
pour autant 2 règles importantes :
1) limiter les dérangements et
2) ne jamais ouvrir le nid.
Seule solution pour voir ce qui
se passe à l'intérieur de nosboîtes,
se procurer un nichoir équipé d'une
petite caméra. Avec ça, émotions garanties!
Voilà, c'est tout pour aujourd'hui. Je vous
donne rendez-vous au prochain épisode !